this episode brought to you by
stamps.com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience
[Music]
hey what are this yes
Oh Malcolm Tamara take a seat but
there's no chairs I said take a seat
do you remember the Swan Princess review
oh yeah yeah sure I think a lot of
people like that one and do you remember
the characters mr. rooster and Miss
Kitty I think so yeah we voiced them
right because nobody demanded it I
decided to give them a spinoff named
Miss rooster and mr. kitty you know a
rooster can't be female right I don't
see gender only money plus I'm gonna
have them star in all the sketches
moving forward
wait you're replacing us portraying
characters with characters that we've
already portrayed oh yes virtual actors
are the future so you're no longer
needed
farewell don't you just do their voices
though I guess you have a point or
whatever you didn't mention that but we
are gonna have to negotiate no need
you can't bet everything on virtual
actors that nobody's even seen yet well
I think you misunderstood Malcolm I'm
not negotiating with you I'm negotiating
with your characters mr. kitty miss
rooster please come in you see I had
them animated earlier they're the most
perfect virtual characters you can
imagine they will be in all future
sketches play all future characters look
exactly how I want them to look if you
could just read the lines I wrote for
their negotiations that'd be swell well
gee we'd love to but our reach just
doubled Oh everybody associates your
voices with them oh well if you want the
illusion to be ruined no no let me just
write then to the budget here I see okay
fine say the lines
gee mr. critic since we're not real you
can negotiate whatever you want wait why
isn't his mouth moving I must have just
paid for another animation to have them
walk in not two but it in more from lip
movements actual actors Oh Oh what kind
of personality does mr. kitty hat by the
way
Oh none what well I want
be blank slate so people can imagine
them and all the rules that isn't
leaving an impact what would make people
want to see them in other roles why are
you making this so complicated just get
to the part where everything works okay
what movie did you see what anytime you
act weird or weird ern it's because of a
movie that tried the same thing nonsense
just as a key Ross will soon be the most
famous virtual actress in the entire
fantasy so what if it was Final Fantasy
the Spirits Within with something of a
bizarre experiment based loosely on the
popular video game franchise this was
one the first fully computer-generated
movies to attempt to look photorealistic
the median Entertainment has come a lot
further in this technology it still
stands as a pretty damn impressive
effort and an expensive one with a
budget of over a hundred and thirty
seven million dollars it only made 85
million of its money back why was so
much put into a video game movie which
infamously don't get much of return
because no joke this was going to be the
start of casting virtual actors their
main character Akira's was being pushed
as the first virtual character to be in
other movies so you could have the
Incredibles during Aki Ross Polar
Express during Aki Ross maybe even cross
into live-action movies like Bad Santa
with a key Ross or Ken the hell with the
key Ross I don't know so an idea on the
one hand the lines of artistic identity
are being blurred all the time with
animated musical groups like gorillas
and Miku being such big heads but
something about this just seems silly I
mean what is doll I'm gonna play a ninja
turtle is Shrek gonna play Superman's
upper lip is General Tarkin gonna play
Jar Jar is sandals gonna play Sonic the
Hedgehog please I guess in children's
video we've kind of done this before
putting Mickey Mouse Bugs Bunny and the
Muppets in different roles but that's
usually more for Laughs and even then
they usually don't stray far away from
their well-known personalities they
don't act much different outside of the
characteristics we already know them for
which is exactly what acting is supposed
to be for the most part
I mean if a key Ross played sadness and
inside out does that mean we couldn't
change the way she look to match the
character because it's already a design
virtual actress or what are we more of
her to look like the character kind of
defeating the purpose of the virtual
actress the whole thing's a little odd
but people the time were convinced this
was going to be the next big thing she's
one of a hundred women who may change
the cultural landscape
perhaps the movie star of the summer
indeed the perfect plan isn't it miss
rooster damn that something went wrong
with the render at night the pay the
animators overtime oh hey I'm a phone
with Phil Lamarr he says the virtual
character he's playing may want to voice
mr. kitty Oh heavy phil lamarr attached
could be a big draws probably gonna cost
more than me though okay fine it's worth
having a celebrity like that playing the
perfect character playing the perfect
character playing the part of a
character but because Final Fantasy
bombed so hard the idea was dropped
faster than a sequel to Simone Vic to
the brave you'll remember that movie I
acknowledge its existence so why did
Final Fantasy fail to find a real
audience with its virtual characters oh
let's take a look this is final and
unlike the games I do actually mean
Final Fantasy the Spirits Within do you
still need us no get out of here but
with our virtual characters still here
we might need to voice those ha I don't
have a budget right now to animate them
leaving no we're very method and we go
wherever our characters go look an
off-camera alien took them away what's
the aliens name out you might be able to
start a future sketches ah it's virtual
deal is getting worse all the time
I guess the Columbia torch is now a
lightsaber oh because sci-fi as we open
insight Jared Leto's brain and find it
full of those things Jack skilling Tim
likes to walk down
[Music]
whoa like the movie script and nothing
is there yet somehow it's supporting me
every night the same dream
this is dr. Akira's voiced by ming-na
wen who keeps having dreams of an alien
world it's been 34 years since they
arrived on this planet out a day passes
that the survivors forced to live in
barrier cities do not live in fear
I believe my dreams hold the key will I
be in time to save the earth which it
really puts the dump and Exposition dump
by the way if you don't follow the
game's fear not the movie doesn't either
ironic is the director of the movie
worked on Final Fantasy games before
doing this film and granted each game
has a different story and characters
admit I never followed them that closely
but you can definitely identify a solid
style from them they're big they're
colorful they're imaginative they're
weird they're over-the-top they're a
perfect mix of both science fiction and
fantasy this looks like someone just
pissed a sci-fi Channel movie into a jar
of mud and then tried to animate Mars
Needs Moms 2 out of it it's not
necessarily lazy it's just standard even
for back then this is all the typical
sci-fi stuff you saw everywhere the
music even tries to make such
run-of-the-mill imagery sound much
grander that actually is
my god a ship landing on earth I haven't
seen that since everything huh damn
Powerpuff Girls playing tag again
dr. Ross lands in New York to see if
more than product placement survived the
apocalypse
I would wear more protective space
combat gear but my hair sensor gun sound
like the little girl's hair being pulled
oh no the generics an alien race made
out of other alien races from other
movies showing the two world chorus said
we'll get along great with the spirits
Korra said several soldiers land though
and fight off the hollows berm just what
the hell do you think you're doing the
life-form in here I'm taking you in fine
arrest me but I'm not leaving without
that life-form but arresting you you
have the right to be arrested I am NOT
even in charge I need a minute to
extract it she finds what she's looking
for inside a plant but more space shrimp
tried to attack
music stop confusing nothing for
something it's nothing that was a final
fantasy movie it blows that doesn't
Ghostbuster reboot it come as promised
it was worth the lives of you and your
men she thinks you're making she's an
idiot I know you're not a man I think
you're an idiot too
very funny is it captain Grey played by
Alec Baldwin
of course reveals that him and doctor
Ross used to be an item and is also
Archer nice to see you too I'm sorry I
can't hear you over the sound of my
giant throbbing erection
oh come on no grand music on that
standard size I shot getting scanned the
other soldiers played by usually
distracting voices steve buscemi fing
rains and peri gilpin all sounds so
freakin distinct that it's impossible to
connect them coming out of these CG
puppets it just sounds like the
criminals from Fargo and out of sight
are calling rise to get on the dr. crane
show so these skin is a probably worse
was these machines are suspected of
causing sterility and I want to have a
little Neil jr. calling me daddy someday
that's a spooky thought oh no doubt
about it they're gonna make it to the
end bullshit captain
they got him there must be a mistake you
came in contact with the Phantom sir
please remain calm
well that almost makes me have a facial
expression I can't start having a
personality now what level is he blue
it'll be called red in three and a half
minutes now that is the third saddest
thing I've heard today
Wow the suspense I have for these human
military catchphrases I've known for
only a minute is really drawing me in
dr. Ross saves him by zapping the alien
phantom inside his body I'm told this
represents human emotion clearly didn't
work it's alright
your chin is still two-thirds your body
what's with her in the captain what's
with her and that stupid plant what no
really what I think you forgot to write
a joke Donald Sutherland reprises his
role as smart old guy as he talks with
dr. Ross about finding one of the
missing spirits they're looking for in
the plant spirits I thought we weren't
supposed to use the S word don't get
smart with me you'd be the first person
in this movie to do so weirder things in
this movie isn't me now when is known
for being a really great voice actress
like giving solid performance after
solid performance every time I don't
know if it was just bad direction if
there was a time crunch but her delivery
throughout the entire film seems more
computer-generated than her character is
you made it possible to harness that
energy for ovale pack scanners even the
barrier the council knows that they
trust you dr. Danny I think I seen my
mom and dad in the audience hi mom and
dad I'm a doctor
a doctor there is a war going on no
one's young anymore can we unless she
pretends to be a boy for some reason I
don't know how we're just positive it'll
add more life to her scenes no sorry you
have to see that but you know how it is
when you get those are manly urges our
ideas are unpopular okay if you have any
notes or records that could be used
against you destroy them oh come on
science being a popular especially in an
age of computers that seems far-fetched
dr. Ross and smart old guy go to the
counsel of space choosey things and make
their case that defeating the alien race
known as the Phantom's with a giant
cannon is not a good idea and don't you
hate it when he can't tell who the bad
guy is could you please explain why
Zeus was completed a month ago seeing
how I'm played by James Woods it clearly
should have been called Hades
we have reconvened today to vote on that
very issue again my god
is anybody ugly in this movie can
someone have a zit when we increase the
laser power facility per particles as
you all know is the number one line to
warn you that you're in a shitty movie
as you know one of the laziest uses for
exposition because as stated many times
before if it's already known why is it
being said as you all know as you may
know you know I conducted a raid on the
great library did you pretty much put it
on a movie's tombstone as soon as as
mentioned so as you know the Phantom's
nest is in the meteor that hit Earth
washed up ohmic matrix code here wants
to blast it smart old guy says it's not
a good idea because it'll hurt the Earth
Spirit yep that's what we're doing in
Julius you mean the Gaia
I mean you mean the spirit of the earth
yes she's going through eighth grade
planted to your bodies the way
centipedes have gone through socks for
the sake of our children we cannot risk
this even if Gaia does exist won't we
still have to remove the Phantom's but
there is an alternative to the space
Kenner please as we know the really as
you know pink is a colour salt is salty
and the writer for this is never getting
hired again he suggests using several
hidden spirits whose energy can cancel
out the phantoms but as of now they're
not all discovered gathering plants and
animals to fight the Phantom's is utter
nonsense
oh he said the N word some army of
touchy-feely plants and animals by the
way I love James Woods I think he's a
great talent he's hugely entertaining to
watch
but tell me tell me he's not trolling
the movie with this line reads we've
succeeded in containing the particles Oh
where is the proof seriously how much
more please notice me high school drama
teacher can you get where is the proof
you are tearing me apart proof where is
the proof where it's in critic I can't
find your copy of Young Frankenstein
where is oh I'm sorry sir rotted the
minestrone
there is there shit where is dead things
look a deer where is look magic yes
please ha ha look at that ice cream sell
her one of my wisdom teeth fell out
oh that's very fortunate indeed perhaps
I'll get some money tonight oh well you
better head to bed critic indeed Malcolm
[Music]
goodnight little critic good night
Malcolm and Tamara dream of merriment
and joy I
[Music]
[Applause]
cereal what will they think of next
oh hello critic good morning Malcolm and
Tamara sleep well sure did
oh did the fairy come last night why I
got so excited for cereal I don't even
think the check well better go take a
look
[Music]
yeah is the tooth congratulations critic
that was supposed to annoyingly
drawn-out joke you've done in years how
does it feel well you know we were
nervous at first I mean we deliberately
wasted everybody's time I mean the
rebuke just completely disappeared but
you know hopefully we gave some
nightmares out there with the fairy and
I want to thank God and to all the
people I pissed off out there I'm sorry
I'm not emotional words stupid emotional
words I'm from Mohammed and I'm not
talking to a camera right now I'm just
insane dr. oz shows that she is infected
by the phantoms and that the research
has slowed it down
fuck the only way to destroy the
infection without destroying her is
finding the other spirits get have you
been watching this movie but two of the
guys stopped their transport so that
grey of Ross can have some time alone
we're just gonna strand them for a while
we're just helping the captain out of it
come on huh that old cliche of muscle
bound military men trying to hook
couples up
it's a moir baby it's okay it's not
like any of their lifespans or women who
don't wait oh God that's how Maximum
Overdrive started so will you tell me
about them she told them about the
spirits they've collected and the odd
places they've been found the fourth was
a bird never tried to track a sparrow
from outer space what am I saying you
probably would love that you're right I
probably would she's always been known
for his late night Sparrow tracking
fifth was a little girl dying in a
hospital emergency room oh you're not
ready for a scene like this movie you
have to practice with a few spots and
bumpers before you get to do a scene
like this I told her everything had a
spirit dogs cats trees little girls
really yeah it's rightness I told her
that she wasn't dying just returning to
the earth spirit okay I guess I'll give
credit that they're attempting to go
outside their comfort zone but I just
don't really see how this is the
romantic moment the movie was building
up a second ago she told
me but she was ready to die it's a moir
baby only seven years old and ready to
die
it's a moir baby I'm sorry and I mean
that in the most non caring Alec Baldwin
II way I can say that I have to find the
seventh and eighth spirits
oh please shit is he using this as a
means to get in her pants I guess this
was a romantic scene after all know how
much time I have left
mmm kids dying our Hut tell me about the
ending of my girl it's so puts me in the
mood
it's a moir baby blocking trope can
someone please get me a cat from my
black leather gloves to pet I'm trying
to do as many evil red flags as I can
here report any aberrant behavior in dr.
Ross to the major immediately dr. Ross
is a spy the general is wondering why
he's explaining himself to a captain
somehow an animator took von dooms
comically childish sneer face and turned
it into an entire person the general is
wondering why he's explaining himself to
a captain dr. Ross has another dream
about the alien world as it looks like
Robo duck men are going to war and I'm
not gonna lie that's a pretty cool
sentence to say like the audience
everybody's waiting for something to
happen
stones not safe here
two for the team go to find a seventh of
the eighth spear it's in a dangerous
region where phantoms roam the seventh
spirit should be just beyond that line
of wreckage behind the rabbit this was
the Phantom cleansing mission
my father's in here somewhere a survivor
what's it doing out here hoping for life
to return yes most birds follow hope
over instinct Coco Puffs is an addiction
that can be beat they seem to find the
spirit and one of the soldiers backpacks
how do you explain that packs power our
weapons the barrier of cities I mean
it's just by a theory Kenny's wait stop
you're doing your painful exposition
without using the words as you know come
on maybe we can go for three in this
sticker but the Phantom's bind them and
try to hunt them down
yeah that was kind of cool they take off
as two of the soldiers say they have to
take Ross in as her infection attracts
the Phantom's
won't let you do this soldier you're
gonna have to shoot me well that seemed
harsh she's greedy there was scary
I shoot scary oh my god you killed a
hooker
the Phantom's take out the two soldiers
ah they didn't even get to capture the
flag which makes underworld here very
unhappy the divas are returning from the
wasteland sir apparently there was an
incident what was he even doing before
that guy came in doesn't you have any
important work to do evil mm brooding my
hand smells great by tomorrow morning
that council will be at our feet
meanwhile a key seems to be dying and I
don't know you make sense of this she
needs a sympathetic spirit to help hold
her in this world and I can think of no
spirit that are suited for that task
than yours captain so if I just clap my
hands and say I believe in Aki she'll
come back to life well something like
that they set up a device to share the
same dream while he puts the seven
spirit in her it's not that I understand
it I just don't care where are we on an
alien planet you seem pretty calm yes
you're usually so energized and
expressive oh no it's the alien versus
Predator movie even less people wanted
Wow I think actual Castlevania fire
looks more impressive than that
photorealism everybody the dream shows
the aliens destroyed their world and a
meteor was flung into our world so it's
like Superman except instead of aliens
saving the day they made everything
destructive and boring like Superman
[Applause]
[Music]
definitely you should really go to
Stan's comm who did I am your conscience
why does my conscience sound like a 70s
robot the real question is white going
to sound like a 70s robot anyway you
should render go to Stan's calm but why
I'm totally fine with the stance I
usually use yes but you have to go to
the post office to pick them up in with
Stan's comm you can just stay at home
why no one really has time to go to the
post office you're busy who's got time
for all that traffic parking lugging
around all your mail and packages just a
real hassle oh that must be why
stamps.com is one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
what a weird thing to say yes Stan's
calm eliminates unnecessary trips and
saves you money what discounts you can't
even get at the post office you feel
like they'll so specific just the way I
set those words and put them back on
brings all the amazing services of the
u.s. post office right to your computer
but they're a small office sending
invoices and online sellers shipping out
products or even a warehouse sending out
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
it's a simple process - ok who's this
now this is your eyeball my eyeball also
sounds like a seventies robot it's a
coincidence anyway simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just hand it to
a mail carrier or drop it off in a
mailbox that's involved it saves you so
much money - let me guess my stomach why
don't you sound like a seventies robot
we stamp that can't you get 5 cents off
the first-class Stampin Up the point
percent up Priority Mail not to mention
it's a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters good point
conscience this is your eye idiot
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already used dance comm my
eyeball is right it's extremely helpful
whenever I need to send out merchandise
or other product this isn't your eyeball
this is your foot what your foot says
right now everybody can be included in a
special offer we trial plus free postage
a digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to Stan's dad come
click at the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in nostalgia
that's dance background and to nostalgia
anyone else want to say anything
Chaplin how about you cactus - back down
and enter nostalgia today
[Music]
[Applause]
so while adorable wolfenstein nazi sits
around again not doing any real work
just continuing to brood my wife and
daughter
but killed by phantoms when the San
Francisco barrier I'm trying to give him
character now he looks like the cool
older brother of Neil Patrick Harris
from Starship Troopers I think all
credibility assailed he tries sabotaging
one of the bases so that the council
will be more desperate to go with his
plan now realizing he's letting the
Phantom's get too close breach in Sector
thirty-one general relax major when this
nights over you're going to be a hero
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha meanwhile our
heroes get captured and try to figure
out what a key and grey's dream meant
the meteor is a chunk of their planet
that got thrown into space when they
destroyed their world I feel like she's
gonna tell me what number I reached and
then instruct me to leave a message what
meteor turns you into momentum a how
could they survive the trip across outer
space on a hunk of rock they didn't
they're not an invading army they're
ghosts yeah how's that for a twist the
creatures that were known as spirits and
phantoms we're ghosts next you'll be
telling me drinks are actually beverages
sir I have numerous phantom contacts
speaking of dead weight the phantoms
break in too far past security and begin
wiping out the barrier rig
relax your hero wah-ha-ha-ha remember he
learned his lesson enough to do it just
one more time near the end of the movie
yeah your attempts at sympathy work as
well as Hitler giving us sorry things
got out of hand card bars are pulsonic
lasers I mean it's not like I can just
wave a magic wand and hey my voice was
so nasally it short-circuited the doors
I think we should proceed
[Applause]
this was a full scene and a button see
this movie has earned two points picture
- I'm four-wheeler that somehow sounds
like a go card we need to buy my ship if
it was told inside the city it would be
in the military hangar I may have to use
a whole horsepower on this thing but
they crash causing one of them to get
injured we'll find the ship and be back
for you look at that face
so they run to the ship so they can come
back for him are they leisurely stroll
you know he doesn't get in the way of
this nice relaxing walk opens up the
lungs even though his will be closed
soon it's still nice there's the problem
to get the ship moving though two of
them have to go down to tinker with some
wires you think we're gonna get out of
here alive I mean I wonder if anybody
else has gotten out what if it's all a
bunch of mumbo-jumbo Wow
Jane do you mind if we stop talking I'm
trying to concentrate here
[Music]
yeah we're taking that point back but
the phantoms catch up with them he went
out like he lived
tragically unfunny well it's like they
say in the military when the going gets
tough buy a key sees what's going on and
decides to help we're in countdown to
liftoff one week it's too dangerous
Aki well I did all I could maybe I'll
miss her
the team gets wiped out except for dr.
Roz gray and smart old guy who fly out
of there hey I know a lot of people are
dead but I'm kind of horny
these two people want the ball get the
most morbid times more than Gomez and
Morticia Addams toupee tonight I enlarge
the scanning perimeter yeah she enlarge
my scanning perimeter too it looks like
both them and slimy del slime slime are
going to the crater where it looks like
the final spirit is located that's a
one-way trip and then we wait that's
your plan we wait and see what happens
yes you learn that in med school that
you obviously didn't get into a key and
gray go down to the crater just before
it gets blasted hurting the Earth's
feelings general han you must cease fire
immediately what you are looking at in
the crater is the living spirit of an
alien's homeworld
she recorded this in a day the cost
maybe the entire planet sir chun-li you
is laughing at you he of course refuses
and keeps firing as Granick 'i come
across the guy and all her blue kool-aid
glory that's not what I think it is is
it
yes it's Gaia so planet spirits are
Smurfs not good to know I know as a
villain I shouldn't say this but piece
of candy I guess one of the Phantom's is
a compatible spirit but they don't know
which one yet not that it matters much
as dr. ross does which he does best in
this movie being passed out
nope God was this just the longest
build-up to the most expensive tentacle
hand-tight cuz i weirdly respect that um
does internet porn know you're cheating
on it
with the hope of new life as Gaia
changed the phantom within do you hear
me Sid the wave pattern is complete I
don't know what happened I use mere IMDB
yet um you're on ER you're dr character
quinn save this performance the final
spirit finds her and they use all the
spirits to try and stop the beam but
Dartz face ball actually uses so much
energy and his laser beam that it ends
up nuking the entire ship
Jesus this guy could turn on a light
switch without blowing a place off but I
never got my prey gray is injured though
and dr. Ross tries to keep him alive
with all her heart
don't leave me grey hang on please I
still have the wave what kind of beam
when she hit with a blue Kshama
lighnator it's kind of confusing what
happens next but somehow grace
sacrifices himself by mixing his body
and her spirit with the Phantom's body
and spirit baby do you care I'll miss
you and all three of your jaw lines Wow
like peach chutney eyes babe
whatever he did it made everything
better as we're given the last line of
the movie the same thing you'd say when
your hot pockets done deep you look
stupid and he like stupid you both suck
and that's it that's exactly where it
ends
mmm I mean it says good a reaction as
anything else
so yeah this movie is pretty dull and
sadly very lifeless the movie
encompasses way too much sci-fi instead
of a sci-fi fantasy mix but even if it
did it would still have the same stock
characters and dialogue that you would
get from Wow a very uninspired videogame
ethical level I'll give it credit all
the visuals are pretty sterile compared
to other sci-fi it still was a
breakthrough and how realistic an entire
CG movie could look sure it's a tad
dated now but these were big steps in
making CGI more convincing both in
totally animated movies and blending in
with live-action movies and yeah
obviously you can't have a virtual
actress and other movies if there's
nothing engaging about the actress
outside of the fact that she's virtual
you have to give the people something
cool first if you wish for them to want
to see more and you know I'm sorry that
took you two for granted from now on
I'll recognize acting talent in flesh
and blood rather than the virtual realm
thank you critic yeah we really
appreciate okay that's all you paid us
for wait what are you two doing we
negotiated remember we let you use our
Malcolm and Tamara characters for the
amount of time you paid for wait so
Malcolm and Tamara were virtual actors
this whole time no you dumbass they're
doing our voices remember yeah we're
still virtual characters we just made
two other virtual characters of Malcolm
tamra that we boost well them where's
the real Malcolm Tamara oh we killed
them what are you talking with her they
recorded them earlier we just predicted
what you were going to say oh come on no
one that energy is peanut butter hey man
go super magnetism oh god you are
geniuses yeah you should have created us
so perfect it's only logical that this
would be the natural progression of
using virtual actors well I'm not a
virtual actor I'm a real man
flesh and blood and there is no way that
I'm gonna okay Chester you can stop whoa
I'm sorry it's just so much fun to
imagine he's real you want to catch a
bite
[Music]
if you make these its way this creature
in these we've hit in a wire better than
that where's the proof joke
they still don't get that in Samar a
baby
hey Doug Walker here Huntington's
disease Society of America as this
week's charity shoutout Huntington's
disease is a fatal genetic disorder that
causes the progressive breakdown of
nerve cells in the brain today there are
approximately 30,000 Americans that
suffer from this and more than 200,000
at risk inherent in the disease
Huntington's disease Society of America
is the premier nonprofit organization
dedicated to improving the lives of
everyone affected by this disease from
community services and education to
efficacy and research they are the
world's leader in providing help for
today and hope for tomorrow in the
battle against Huntington's disease this
organization makes sure nobody fights
alone if you look at their site you can
see all the ways they fight for a cure
and help those who have to live with it
they work endless hours to help
countless people and you can play a big
part in helping them out click on the
link and show your support
you